g7 economies came together to agree
the post-pandemic world must be fairer
what you're seeing
is a revival of multilateralism
a willingness of leading nations
to cooperate to address the most
critical
challenges facing the global economy
what you just heard was janet yellen
biden's treasury secretary announcing
the u.s
would be joining an economic suicide
pact
basically to set a global minimum
corporate tax rate now it's not just a
horrible deal it's going to punish
american companies and workers
it strips power from voters and hands it
to the global bureaucrats remember we
said it earlier in the show they don't
really like democracy
we've been warning you about this for
months it was coming this is the great
reset
and it's in full swing joining us now
larry kudlow former trump white house
economic advisor
host of the fantastic fox business show
kudlow larry um i have to imagine that
china is laughing
as america makes this move to sign over
our tax policy to
a global confab
yeah i mean listening to yellen first of
all i
i don't want these multilateral
organizations
to do anything actually and to give up
our tax
sovereignty uh and you're right the way
you just put it
um it gives up voter sovereignty for
heaven's sakes you know this thing came
up
periodically under president trump and
he would always say
the only people who can decide american
tax policy
are american voters okay not the g7
not the oecd not the g20 by the way
all this does is jack up taxes even
more there's a provision in there laura
besides the
15 percent minimum tax which is bad
enough there's a new provision that
hasn't been
accurately and adequately reported yet
and that is
if a company has a 10 or more
profit margin which is not all that much
particularly after getting clobbered by
the pandemic
then this deal would allow that company
to be taxed
up to 20 percent or even
more now that is remarkable that is so
antagonistic to capital formation
investment
plants and equipments jobs real wages
family incomes as the most remarkable
deal
for treasury secretary of the united
states to do it is absolute surrender
and here's what transportation secretary
your old pal larry p buddha judge said
yesterday about this whole new
global minimum tax deal watch we're
going to end this race to the bottom
uh by getting the the g7 countries to
agree to a global minimum tax so the
idea is corporations would pay at least
15 percent and they couldn't go race to
some other country to get a lower tax
rate right because the system right now
creates a real incentive to park your
profits and sometimes even your jobs
overseas
larry can i can think of another some
other country that will benefit from
this of course china
by the way that's uh not a small point
because china will not they have not
participated
in any of these discussions and they
will not play
by any of those rules china under
biden's tax policies china will have
significantly lower
business taxes than the united states
does and china will have significantly
lower
capital gains taxes than the united
states does and of course this may
only be the beginning unless it's all
stopped i mean look this race to the
bottom
you know who wins their waste to the
bottom ireland with a 12
and a half percent corporate tax rate
you know who put us on the right road
donald trump who took the corporate tax
from 35
to 21 and he didn't have any of these
excess profits taxes the idea
that raising your taxes is going to keep
companies
or jobs here it's just i mean it's
counter-intuitive
it's utter nonsense people will flee
just as they did before the trump
tax cuts but again this is remarkable
because
with so much ease so far our u.s
treasury and presumably the white house
is willing to give away
our sovereignty who's running this
country
is the oecd run in this country is the
g7 run in this country
or are the voters and businesses and
workforce of the united states run in
this country
that's a question they don't like this
country i'm going to say what you won't
say
yeah i'm gonna say what you won't say
because you're you're just too nice
okay diplomatic larry a lot of these
people don't like the country that much
i'm sorry they think america
is pollutes too much consumes too much
it's systemically racist has is one is
generally
white supremacists are the real problem
so it should be
brought down to a level race to the
bottom whatever you want to call like
everybody else
so we should be as miserable as european
countries
who would prefer to be locked down i
don't know for the next five years
because of covet so they
it it goes very deep this is a this is
the klaus schwab reset
first step of many steps
well look at i i actually have said so
many people on this progressive left do
not like america
and they want to change our culture they
want to change our history and they want
to destroy
our economy look they may not admit it
they have no interest in economic growth
or prosperity
or worker jobs and wages they want
redistribution
they want to punish success and now
they're willing to do it on a grand
global scale so we will lose
europe will have lower taxes than we
will china will have
lower taxes than we will it's a scorched
market
you know biden's idea is just sort of
what this is like some great
workers paradise that's what this is and
it's nutty yeah it's nutty as a
reference larry thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else